[Musique]
comment
claude dubos vous fait un retour dans le
passé avec une petite nouvelle
compilation du bois solide mais aussi
avec l'événement virtuel l'histoire de
mes chansons je revenir sur cette photo
où on voit avec une guitare
vous avez quel âge là dessus 12 ça
correspond quand j'enregistrais claude
dubois et ces montagnards mais sa
célébrité c'est la guitare de mon frère
celle là c'est une photo qu'on a faits
puis j'avais pas le droit de la prendre
alors je me cachais dans un garde-robe
pour être sûr que personne n'entend pour
parfaire stoli et je grattais 7 buts en
rien faire et les années ont passé de
peu je me suis retrouvé chez un voisin
tout des gaspésiens ça gratte aide à
l'italie soir au matin ça a été mon
école c'est comme ça vous avez appris
par absolument absolument à est sûre du
country away votre voix prend beaucoup
de place dans vos chansons bien entendu
mon oubli
claude dubois le guitariste vous avez
toujours aimé cet instrument que la
guitare ça ça c'est une partie
intégrante de votre personnalité de qui
vous êtes
on n'avait pas les moyens d'être
pianiste aw c'était l'objet le plus
simple que beaucoup de voisins avait que
la vie avec la facilité de ces ça pue
tellement être de monde une guitare ça
peut être d'une largeur incroyable j'ai
bien
j'aime bien
claude dubois la première fois que j'ai
entendu c'était sur un 45 tours avec
d'un côté ce bébé j'ajoute à thoune et
de l'autre cette chanson la première que
j'ai apprise à la guitare
[Musique]
ouais là tout le monde chante c'est
comme ça que ça marche
[Musique]
mais après tu prends juste son refrain
et id elle est d'une simplicité
ah ouais je vis reconnu tout comment
vous l'avez composé comme la rue j'ai
d'abord fait la musique puis je me suis
retrouvé dans un studio à los angele il
y avait la gagne de nancy sinatra qui
m'accompagnait un coup de pouce que j'ai
eu d'abord et puis j'ai écrit les le
texte sur la console il manque en tout
et c'est ça qui est le plus poignant
[Musique]
on dit que les plus grandes chansons
sont composées plus rapidement parfois
on dirait que ce n'est pas une question
de durée de temps c'est ça arrive comme
ça j'ai quand même eu un petit bout de
temps forts de la mélodie effectivement
tu as raison c'est du sud chasse-galerie
c'est la même chose quelqu'un ça a été
écrit c'est un coin de et j'ai utilisé
la vieille légende que j'ai pu utiliser
comme je pouvais parce que je me
rappelais pas tout
[Musique]
je vous ai vu un concert au théâtre des
variétés au casino théâtre saint denis
ce qu'ils reçoivent dans ses trémolos
dans votre voix à la façon dont vous
allez chercher certaines notes
à quel âge et à quel moment précis vous
avez trouvé votre voix votre sont leurs
sont closes et ça va se développer
je pense par la force des choses comme
je dit il fait plusieurs spectacles
qu'il ya eu des périodes dans ma vie où
j'étais moins somnifères et touche
bougeait beaucoup alors il pouvait
m'arriver des fois d'avoir veillé la
veille
et voilà j'arrive avec une voix cassée
fatigué et je développais des techniques
de respiration des techniques de da
proches au niveau musique que 6ème année
la voix score sait trop quoi faire pour
que ça sente bien
c'est tout des techniques qui ceux qui
se sont présentés et que j'ai épousé une
après l'autre
[Musique]
comme un fruit dont on se lasse
bertrand
les temps changent ou le savent et
claude dubois comment on chante plein de
tendresse aujourd'hui c'est l'histoire
d'amour d'un jeune de 15 ans avec une
femme de 30 ans oui et c'est merveilleux
je n'ai pas de préjugés c'est le
problème de l'information moi j'ai pas
de problème avec ça moi l'ailé les
préjugés actuelle de tout surtout le mot
am le mot en b le mot ceux ci le maux de
tête
alors moi je marche pas là dedans c'est
des choses qui m'intéressent pas moi
j'ai toujours respecté les gens qui me
respecte et j'ai jamais regarder d'où il
venait
salir rien alors je vais pas aujourd'hui
prendre ces pilules alors je lisais la
mesure où rester libre jusqu'au bout
absolument quand même c'est une
nécessité
plein de tendresse et une histoire vraie
oui bah oui un peu exagéré évidemment un
peu plus à gérer ces des rêves d'enfants
claude dubois merci beaucoup pour cette
belle rencontre est bien gentil salut